tu as une paire de sensibilité une paire
de force une perte de motricité perte
d'équilibre j'ai trop abusé du protoxyde
et du coup bah ça m'a fait des effets
neurologiques très très graves et qui
peuvent être irréversibles
j'ai une neuropathie donc des jambes
c'est une paresthésie des membres
inférieurs donc en gros j'ai eu au
niveau du bassin jusqu'au bout des pieds
aucune sensibilité donc tu perds la
sensibilité ça veut dire que quand tu
prends ta douche tu mets l'eau froid ou
chaud tu sens pas sur tes jambes
clairement donc ça veut dire que quand
tu as pas la vision du sol donc tu sais
pas si tu marches sur du coton si tu
marches sur du béton si tu marches sur
de l'herbe tu as pas aucune adhésion
donc tu n'as pas d'équilibre donc j'ai
ça j'ai mon releveur de pieds qui se
relève plus donc ça veut dire que mon
pied il est toujours tombant au lieu de
pouvoir se relever quand tu fais la
marche moi il se relève plus parce que
les nerfs ils ont été atteints
mais genre
un kiné avec tout ça peut vraiment
t'aider pour la
trop voyant moi
on dirait vraiment
c'est moi la meuf je vois un
addictologue tous les deux mois
obligatoire parce que c'est une
addiction le protoxyde d'azote c'est une
drogue il faut le mettre le mot vraiment
sur les c'est pas un gaz il avance pas
marrant en fait quand tu es pas bien
dans ta tête bah tu tombes dedans et tu
consommes tu consommes tu consommes à
outrance à ne pas te rendre compte que
c'est vraiment dangereux pour ta santé
malgré les logos qui a sur les bonbonnes
malgré tout ça on en prend pas
conscience c'est vraiment c'est
important que les jeunes ils soient au
courant de ce qui peut y avoir comme
répercussions avec le protoxyde d'azote
j'ai fait des erreurs dans ma vie et ça
c'en est une grosse et au moins si je
peux véhiculer un bon message en faire
part aux gens bah je le fais parce que
beaucoup de gens ont et ont peur et n'en
parle pas aux médecins ils ne vont pas
consulter il reste comme ça
[Musique]
c'est que on peut directement obtenir
des colonnes là c'est la plus
importante donc là on avait les
conditionnements on va dire une mission
historique une dose avec la capsule
qu'on met dans les crèmes à siphon pour
chantilly et puis on a eu le la montée
un de ces conditions qui représente à
peu près 80 à 100 capsules donc vous
voyez qu'il y a des conditionnements
avec des couleurs des pistons donc ça
c'est juste utilisé de façon récréative
on peut pas faire de la crème chantilly
avec ça là on voit la version la version
qui contient un équivalent de 400 à 600
de ses capsules c'est vrai qu'avant on
devait consommer sans capsules dans les
voyez c'est sans capsule maintenant on
consomme une bonbonne donc c'est vrai
qu'on se dit plutôt moi j'ai fait deux
trois bons bonnes sur la soirée
avec son téléphone donc
c'est quoi le se présente dans le hall
de salle en gros
[Musique]
en fait ce patient il a abîmé toute sa
moelle épinière sur tout le long de sa
moelle épinière et comme c'est par là
que passe toutes les informations
sensitives qui viennent des mains qui
viennent des pieds elles peuvent pas
arriver au cerveau il tient à peine
debout patient là et ça on sait par
expérience que la récupération elle est
extrêmement lente une fois qu'on est à
ce stade là il va falloir des mois de
prise en charge rééducative pour lui
apprendre à marcher ça servir des bras
pour avoir des mouvements précis etc
dès qu'on a des symptômes il faut pas
les banaliser il faut consulter et
surtout arrêter tout de suite c'est le
seul traitement à l'heure actuelle de la
complication neurologique de la
consommation de protoxyde d'azote
[Musique]
on va regarder effectivement ici
beaucoup Ivan
on a également des carences on est
confronté quand même maintenant à une
prise massive et on sait pas trop ce que
ça fait à long terme on connaît quelques
effets à court terme les effets
neurologiques un cardiologiques qu'on a
observé d'où l'intérêt aussi de
délaissés cliniques qu'on est en cours
de mener c'est vraiment de trouver ces
cibles biologiques pour trouver
également dans le futur des traitements
adaptés
[Musique]
on se rend compte que c'est un gros
problème de santé publique avec des
séquelles bien plus lourdes que d'autres
produits qui sont stupéfiants
aujourd'hui nous ce qu'on propose c'est
pas mal de choses dans ce texte mais
deux principales la première c'est
délictualiser la consommation on a
essayé de définir un cadre juridique qui
permet d'avoir le même type de sanction
que pour une consommation de stupéfiante
puisque ça en fait les mêmes
conséquences le ministère de la Santé
qui a des moyens pour le faire devrait
lancer une grande campagne de
sensibilisation et d'information sur le
protoxyde et ses effets auprès des
jeunes parce que je pense qu'il y a
encore beaucoup de jeunes et de famille
qui ne mesurent pas les conséquences sur
la santé d'une telle consommation